good recording okay great
so uh
we're looking to construct a process
with
these uh three properties
and here's here is one way to
construct it just to convince you
that such a process exists so first of
all we know that this process
so this is this is the t-axis
and this is the bt axis
we know that this process is always
going to be
on one of these two lines
because of property two so
you know it can either be on them or
jump between them
and i guess the way that makes the most
sense
to construct it is just take a breath an
actual brownian motion
and
what what what we can do is
try to kind of change the time or
maybe okay let me formally write it
and then explain what i'm writing
so let's define tau of t
to be the minimum time so
let's suppose that w of
s is an actual brownian motion in r
and le and define this continuous
uh sequence of stopping times
tau of t is just the minimum s
such that w of s
in absolute value is equal to t so look
at the first time where
the brownian motion reaches any t by
absolute value
and then define you know b
of t to be just
equal to w at
tau of t
so to know where my
process be is at time t
i look at the first time that the
brownian motion hits t an absolute value
and i look and i see if it was plastic
or minus
ronan it might be good to
you know remind people a little bit
about running motions because this is
like a new character in this uh lecture
series so if you're using some
properties
right um
so so so i think what i'll do is i'll
just give an alternative definition to
the
for this process because i don't want to
i mean yeah i i i think if
if you're if you if you're okay with
brownian motions then this is
a good way to define it but otherwise i
think the best
intuition is just
do do you think poor's on point process
is
fine or this is also something
that okay let me write an alternative
definition
okay but first i mean i i just
just to draw a picture you know so this
process
really goes on these lines and
once in a while it jumps up or down like
this
and these times where the process
jumps this is a sequence of times
between 0 and 1.
let's denote this by
j sub i so this is the
set of times
where b
t i jumps
either from minus minus t to t or
the other way around and
j sub i is going to be
a poisson i'll i'll
define this in a few seconds that was on
point process
with intensity
1 over 2 t what does this
mean so this means that
um so j i is a random subset of the
interval
0 1 and
it's uniquely defined by the following
properties
so the expectation so it's
it's uniquely defined by the two
following properties
for all for every subset
of my time axis zero one
the expectation
of the number of
jumps
he intersected with this set the number
of
jumps inside this set is going to be
equal to the
integral of the over the set a of this
one over two t
dt
and the second property that uniquely
defines it
is that if a and b
are disjoint
sorry if and b are disjoint
then j
i intersection with a and j
i intersection with b are independent
okay so i mean if if you want you can
just
think about you know it's kind of like
okay i guess you can either take a
poisson random variable
okay it would be much easier for me to
give an alternative definition if this
integral
would be convergent and not divergent
it's divergent near zero so except for
some
issue near zero we're near zero we're
actually going to
exhibit infinite many jumps
in this little thing here except for
this we can kind of think you know
take a usual poisson variable
and then uh generate the
locations of the jumps uniformly
okay but i mean
an important property that we'll have is
that
given that we know everything that
happened until some
point in time what's going to happen in
the future
the locations of jumps in the future
are going to be independent from what we
saw
so far okay
good so so and jumps are becoming
more and more rare as we yes
they're becoming more and more air and t
only goes up to time one
so you know when we get to time one the
rate is like one half
and near zero the rate is much much
faster
we which kind of okay i guess it
kind of makes sense with the fact that
this is a martingale because
you know if if
okay let me
and the intensity has to be this one
over two t
to be a martingale exactly that's the
intensity you have to pick
for this thing to be a martial exactly
yeah and and like the the only thing
that
you know we didn't quite
uh that's not quite well defined is that
i didn't tell you what's the value of b
bt
at the time of the jump is it left
semi-continuous
or right semi-continuous you know at
this time
where i have the jump is it equal to
you know this value
or to this value but
it's not gonna matter and this is why
i'm not even gonna tell you
i mean it's really a technical issue
that's
not important
okay so
now here's uh
so so some facts
the first fact is that obviously b
at time one is uniformly distributed
in the hypercube right because
every coordinate is a martingale so
for every coordinate i have you know
fifty percent chance to be plus one
fifty percent chance to be minus one
everything is uniformly distributed
two if i look at f
of b of t
okay just to remind you i we started
with some fixed function
we took this multilinear extension
and then as the argument to this
multi-linear extension i'm taking this
you know strange jump process
then
f of b of t is you know it's the the sum
of those things evaluated
at b of t so i mean let's write it
so this is the sum over
subsets
the fourier coefficients times
when i have a question just actually i
don't really know one emotion that's
well
um is it independent in each coordinates
i mean we we defined it so so that it's
independent in its coordinates i
i only told you how to construct one
coordinate and then i told you
take all coordinates all the coordinates
yeah this is
and now this product
well this is a product
of iid martingales
a product of iid martingales is itself
a martingale okay
so every summoned here is a modern girl
so it's the sum of martingales so this
entire thing
is a martingale
okay was it important that they are iit
or just that they are independent
uh just that they are independent for
this purpose
right so you could maybe imagine like
taking different processes on each
corner
not that i see how yeah it looks like it
would be a lot of fun
but i don't know how yeah
it's possible um okay
so so maybe now let me just repeat what
i
told you during the break um
there are many martingale proofs on the
discrete hypercube
where we consider a slightly different
kind of modern girl
so so if you look at this jump process
it's it's kind of sorry it's kind of a
strange
way to sample from the uniform measure
in the discrete hypercube we're
basically sampling
from the uniform measure we don't sample
everything all at once but we introduce
some
time axis and we
sample more and more bits of randomness
as time continues as time increases
there is an even more natural way to
introduce
time axis in this setting
which is just sampling coordinates one
by one
right instead of sampling all the
coordinates together
we can sample coordinates one by one
and then we can look at the
corresponding
martingale that we get so you know we
can
look at the martingale m i
to be the expectation of f
at you know x which is
uniformly distributed conditioned on x
1 up to x i
okay this i put this in brackets we're
not going to do this but
you've probably seen at least one proof
where this is what you do you sample
coordinates one by one your time axis is
this you know coordinate sampling and
you consider the mar the martingale
where i have
uh this uh coordinate filtration
what we do here is we also
introduce a time axis but instead of
sampling coordinates but one by one
we sample all the coordinates together
only we kind of add the randomness
infinitesimally in some sense
when we so now our time axis is
continuous
and we when we go from t to t plus
very small dt most chances are
no coordinates at all is going to jump
but there are some chances that one of
the coordinates is going to jump
and whether or not a coordinate jumped
and
and which one jumped this is this is
basically the randomness that we're
adding
okay so you you can also think about
this
you know as time as time uh
goes from zero to one i have more and
more
entropy for my uh
i have more and more mutual information
between my location
and the final location kind of
continuously
add more information okay
so this is what's going on and you know
the analysis
is going to take derivatives of this
process f of bt with respect to time
okay okay so
here's a uh
useful fact about martingales and for
this fact
i need a definition
the quadratic variation
of a stochastic process or a martingale
so suppose uh m
t is some stochastic process
actually okay
the definition is uh is really
deterministic but we're going to use it
for
stochastic processes
we define m in those
square brackets t to be
the supremum
over sequences
of times increasing sequences of times
t1 t2 etc
up to t of the sum
or maybe it's so those are not infinite
up to tk which is at most t
the sum i goes from 1 to k
of m at
uh maybe let me put this t not as a
subscript but in brackets
so that it matches what we have above
m of t i
minus m t i minus
1 square
so it's you know it's almost like the
total variation
of this process viewed as a function
only i put a square here i look at the
sum of the
squares of the differences
of m okay
so this is called quadratic variation
and a so t
0 is zero and t k is t maybe
yeah t 0 is 0 and t k
t k i mean k can be equal to t
if you want doesn't matter equal or
small or equal
i mean it actually matters if the
process is not continuous
but yeah so
a useful fact is that the if
empty
is the soup also all k
the soup is also over all k yeah it's
over
okay and also over the t's yeah
if empty is a martingale
then
the variance of
m at any time t
is equal to the expectation of the
quadratic variation
at time t
okay the quadratic variation is a
deterministic
quantity
i look at its expectation sorry the
quadratic variation is
a random quantity
but it only depends on what the process
looks like
i look at the expectation and this
is going to be equal to the variance
uh yes exactly it's any bounded k
it's the supreme over yeah maybe
right
um questions about this fact
okay so you know a word
question from gregory rosenthal
asking should it be infimum rather than
super moon
should it be infimum no it should be
it should actually be super moon
the infimum is like
no i mean it's
it's uh
wait am i confusing
yeah um
for us as long as they're increasing
it's
it's fine
um ah yeah i see what
yeah thanks i mean it's it's a
[Music]
um
i mean the the maybe let me
just say that
the partition should become denser and
dancer yeah i mean this
this definition is is not quite correct
for us
it's correct but let's let's say
that um
so as i'm taking the supreme i want the
difference
the consecutive differences to go to
zero
yeah um sorry about that
okay
you know it's it's like just just think
about this like
you know it's like a riemann integral
it's the same limit as we take in a
riemann
in riemann integration only we we
consider the differences
um okay so
just to recall what we're interested in
is upper bounding
the variance of f at b
of one
all of the above theorems give an upper
bound
for the variance but now given
this fact we can actually
write a nice expression for what this
variance
is going to be
and
the variance of b of 1
is just going to be so let me write this
as a claim
from now on i'm going to i guess do a
lot of hand waving because i don't have
time to make things very rigorous but
i'll try to give you some intuition
about what's going on
so the variance at b of 1 is
the quadratic variation and for jump
processes the quadratic variation if we
look
at this expression well
as long as we have this condition
you know if if i have a continuous
function
and i take the sum of squares
on points like this
then you know as long as the function is
continuous the sum of squares will
converge to zero
right so the only thing that's going to
matter here
is going to be uh the
jumps so for us
what we'll have is that the variance is
just going to be the sum
over i and the sum over t in
jump
in the jump set of the i-coordinates
and here we'll have just
the square of the difference over that
jump which is
f that's b t plus
minus f at b t
minus squared
expectation
okay and
if we look at this
what what is this difference between
those values of
f so
you know suppose our
process bt was at this point when it
jumps it
always almost surely it only jumps in
one coordinate
at each time so we basically compare the
value of
f here to the value of f maybe it jumped
in
you know this horizontal coordinate
the difference between the value of f
here and the value of f here
is just i can i can write it as just
you know the gradient of f
and now this is a continuous gradient
it's not a discrete gradient
it's the gradient of f at b
t
dot
the or maybe
instead of dot let me just say
it's the i derivative of f
at b t times the distance which is
two times t
right and this is what we're gonna
square
and now this expectation is
is just going to be over
whether or not we jumped at a particular
time
t
and using
the
using this fact
i know how many times we expect to jump
at any point in time t and it just
corresponds to this
integral what we'll get
is that this is just going to be
the sum over i
the integral between zero and one
of the expectation
of this square times 2t
squared times the probability that we
jumped
so i'm just i'm now changing replacing
this sum
by you know the expectation of the
indicators of the jumps
which contribute a term that looks like
one over two t
dt just to make sure the integral is
between zero
and one not two and two right zero and
one
thanks yes
okay and yeah
and we're computing variance of f of b
of one right
um yes uh the ah
sorry of f of bit one
of course right
and then in in the first uh
right hand side it's b of t plus
not one right it's like plus a little
right after the jumping right before the
jump board
yeah yeah it's just t plus and t minus
is
yeah right after and right before
there is no one here ah this is this is
the
this is the closing brackets
t minus yeah
um okay so so this
we got some formula i mean let let me
write it a bit differently it's the
integral
between 0 and 1 of the
expectation so uh this
2t squared cancel this
t here cancels out with one of those
things here and we get you know
2 times the expectation t
times the norm of the gradient f
at bt
dt
now this expression
is not new and
it can actually be derived by
applying the usually equation you just
have to figure out
what this thing means but the new thing
in
in our analysis is going to be that
we don't actually have to look at
expectation
we can we can just do a pathwise thing
we can try to figure
out what this process looks like
along a given path
okay and let me try to give you a flavor
of how to do this thing
so um i think
i i have less time than i had planned
to have reaching this point i think i'll
try to
give you an idea we're going to
forget let me go up for a second
we are going to forget about
this inequality because i'm not going to
have
enough time to tell you how to
prove it i think i'll try to give you an
idea of how to reprove this inequality
this strengthening of kkl
using the pathwise approach so without
hypercontractivity i think this is the
best use
of the time we have left okay
so
so let's uh so we're interested in
in you know this quantity
and we're going to define
m i of t
to be so we're just going to
look at those processes
the processes that correspond to the
derivatives
of f rather than f itself
the derivative of f is still a
multi-linear function
so those guys are still martingales
okay and
what i what i i'm going to try to
convince you
is the following thing so first of all
note that m i at time
zero is just the
expectation so since it's a martingale
it's the expectation of
m i time 1 which is just
the average of
the gradient of f
at time 1 so maybe let me just
write it like this
which is obviously at most
the ith influence of f
and this is true even if we
put absolute values here
so why why at most understand the
definitions isn't this
the ice influence or you have squares i
guess right
in front yeah it's the triangle
inequality yeah
there is a square exactly if it if it's
a monotone function then
then this is equal right
and on the other hand
so so i mean maybe let me
write it like this and the square of fmi
of zero
is at most the square of the eighth
influence of
f on the other hand
the expectation of m i
of one squared
is equal to well the expectation of the
squared
of the i derivative of f
at time 1 which is just the unit 4
measure
squared which is
exactly equal to the ice influence
so what we have here is
now let's okay let's assume
[Music]
you know what
um yeah
let's assume without
this we're not gonna lose anything here
uh that m
i of zero is bigger or equal to zero
okay it's not going to matter at all i
mean
even assume the function is monotone
this is not going to
affect generality almost at all
the picture looks like this so
m i of f is a martingale such that
at time 0 this martingale is equal to
the
i-th influence square
at time one
this is time zero at time
one this martingale well
it's equal to either zero or one
obviously because at time one we know
whether whether the ice derivative is
you know zero one at which at the point
where we reached
and in between time zero and time one it
looks maybe
something like this so it's a martingale
it starts from a small value
and it ends up either at zero or at one
again we're thinking about a monotone
function right now
otherwise it could also be minus
one but it doesn't matter so much
okay the main
thing that we're going to prove
is yes
sorry isn't the starting point
i of f why is it a square there
the uh
yeah it's there's no square thanks sorry
about it it starts at i
i of f it finishes at either
one or zero it's it's at one with
probability i i of f
yeah sorry um
[Music]
and what i wanna claim is that
conditioned on the fact that it does
reach this high point one
all the movement is going to be
somehow very close to time one
so the likely scenario is that
it's not going to move at all up to
up to some time one minus delta for
delta very small
and only then it's able to start
moving and actually decide where it goes
and the reason and and somehow the main
inequality
that we're going to see here is
that so so
uh maybe let me write it like this
so
so this is called it's a pretty simple
inequality it's called the
just the level one inequality
but it's it's going to translate into
some very nice
property about this martingale
so there's an inequality saying
that the gradient of
f so maybe let me say it like this
if f is
if it's positive and bounded
then the gradient of f
at a point x in absolute value is at
most
f of x times root log
one over f of x up to some constant
and this
is um maybe a good way to think about it
so
if f is the harmonic extension and
okay i guess there's there's another con
the constant here
depends on the infinity normal fix
think about points which are not very
far from the origin
or maybe ignore this constant it's not
gonna matter
so much for our proof um
let me just try to quickly explain this
inequality for x
equal to zero the gradient
of f at the point zero is just equal
to the integral of x
times f of x
with respect to the uniform measure this
is just due to the fact
that i mean
okay i guess i guess you can just check
it it's
like a summation by parts thing
the gray it's it's the gradient of of a
multi-linear function taking the
gradient is like
multiplying by an x
and
and and the point is that since our
measure is sub-gaussian
then if i have a function
which is
you know between 0 and 1 and i want to
make
that so this thing is just you know the
the
center of mass of
of you know if f is zero is just zero
one then it's the center of mass of the
set
of the set f equal to one
if i want to make the center of mass as
far as possible from the origin
i am i want to push all the mass somehow
in the same direction and then i really
see the subgaussianity
of the uniform measure and we we get
this
inequality it's it's the proof is
actually
like pretty simple but
yeah running this theorem the main
inequality
is an inequality that holds for every
function
uh like what is it what is f here
so f multi-linear extension so it's the
harmonic extension
of every bounded function every positive
bounded function
it's gonna hold and and and this is
somehow it's
it's a very simple inequality the proof
is
you know i kind of made a mess
explaining it but the proof is two lines
and this is really what replaces the
hyper-contractive inequality in our case
and what this is gonna imply
is maybe just to give you an intuition
of
why it implies it
let me go back to you know this formula
here
this formula basically shows you that
the quadratic variation
is you know that or maybe
the quadratic variation which is really
like the rate
the speed in which the martingale moves
at
any given time it depends on the size of
the gradient of f
at this point in time
so if we just take
this inequality and translate it to what
it means about this
martingale i mean we we
we what what we will get is that
the speed
very informally so the speed that
m mit
moves
is bounded
by m
i t root log
one over m i t
okay i didn't exactly say what speed
means but speed is just the
square root of the derivative of the
quadratic variation this is just
if you think if you discretize this
thing and think about the size of
jumps of the martingale the size of
jumps will be bounded by this thing
meaning that as long as the martingale
is small
the jumps that it's making are also
small
now the martingale starts from a very
small value
i mean supposing that most influences
are small if the influence is big
there's nothing to
show but if the influences are small
those martingales are gonna start from a
very small value
and then the level one inequality is
basically going to translate to the fact
that
it just cannot it's it's kind of stuck
in place there is something that keeps
it from moving
as long as it's small and
only near time one there's like some
things can be
exploding and our martingale is
allowed to move
right sorry there's also a factor of
three
the speed there's also a factor of
of uh you mean come coming from here
yeah like this or square root or
something like uh
yeah this this one i think you're
talking about
right yeah
right but anyway like somehow the the
ideology is that
all of the action happens very close to
time one in
in other words if we have if we take uh
a function with small influences and we
look at this process
f of b t then
f of b t will be you know f of bt tells
me
what where i expect the
brown in this jump process to end at the
point where f is equal to one
or at the point of where f is equal to
minus one
almost until time one we're basically
going to have
no idea where we're going to land
okay this is sometimes called noise
sensitivity
and only very close to time one this
level one inequality is going to allow
us
somehow to move which if we go back here
then you know this this integral
instead of i mean that
somehow what we get from it is that
effectively instead of integrating here
from
zero to one we it's it's enough to look
at the integral from some one minus
small delta to one this is the only
place where you can
actually get some contribution for
from this and this is where the log
factor comes from
okay unfortunately i'm out of time
somehow
online talks there's uh
i guess it has something to do with the
speed of light
right whenever i give an online talk
it's
uh time times time goes by much much
faster
than i was planning but i hope at least
i gave you some impression
about some some idea about you know
what's going on in this
proof
thank you very much ronan it was
fascinating
and i guess maybe we can take a few
questions
okay so maybe let me start like
uh you know you can think of other
martingales that also
sort of uh sample
a point in the boolean cube um
what why did you choose this one like
wha how
you came up with this one
um so
i mean i i guess my best answer is
a very natural martingale to sample a
gaussian point is brown is the usual
brownian motion
and there's many things you can prove by
considering this martingale
i mean many things you can improve on
gaussian space
by considering this martingale that
you know samples a point through brown
in motion and
many of these proofs use the fact that
you can
take continuous derivatives with respect
to time somehow
i mean i i guess my main like
the if i have to
to answer in one sentence having
continuous time means you can
differentiate stuff
this is like uh and and and maybe the
natural like you know
and i mean it seems like this is the
natural
counterpart of a brownian motion for the
discrete hypercube
i guess this is
so so let me let me maybe mention what i
had in mind like one
like you could take
right so just like a brownian motion and
you know you want to make it eventually
converge to the
hypercube so you can do like uh
you can slow down if you're coming like
this is actually your paper that you're
slowing down where you're coming uh
close to the hypercube or you can you
know have a sticky brownian motion where
you whenever you reach
one coordinates to either one or minus
one then you stop
so so the question is can you replace
this jump process
by a continuous process that slows down
yeah
um so
many of these things in many of these
examples you can
in uh in the in the proof that i
showed you here there is like a
missing the i'm i i'd really like to be
able to do that
but i couldn't and the missing piece is
that something i kind of skipped over
but there's
there's a log convexity going on it's
it's pretty easy to show that the
expectation of f
of b t squared
or maybe let me write it like this b e
to the minus
s squared is the log
convex function in s
this this fact is like uh actually super
easy
um using like if you write this
in fourier doesn't matter so much and
and like
this uh this thing i don't
know how to extract
this fact when we're not doing the jump
process
other than this somehow everything goes
through
even in a much nicer manner
i think we have another question in the
chat um
right technique allowed to prove the
logs of 11 qualities
so
i mean in
yes so basically you can you can
you can derive hyper contractivity from
this technique
so so so you can basically show that
this uh what i call
level one inequality can be integrated
along the process
and this gives you hypercontractivity
and hypercontractivity is equivalent
to logs overlap i'm not sure if like
this is what you meant
but
so um
so i guess going back to avishai's
question
uh the choice of b of t equal to t was
somewhat uh
special i guess you could have said b of
t equal to t squared or
yes but this would just be you know
some reparameterization of time so as
long
i mean the point is that all of the
coordinates are equal
so so you know it's kind of like it's
kind of like
cheating in the sense that you know i
i'm telling you that
you're inside the continuous hypercube
but
you're really only on these lines
and like one one thing to notice which
i didn't say is that you know when
you're
on for for a specific time t
you're basically sampling from a noisy
version of
f so the points here
just corresponds to you know a noisy
version of
f so i mean in this sense
the this process is just
sampling from noisy versions of f but
like the important thing is that you
have this special
coupling between it's not like you just
consider
different levels of noise you you couple
between them in this very natural way
that gives you a morning yell
there's another question in the chat
can you define a martingale
ah yeah i mean
you can uh so okay
if all the biases are of the same
magnitude
then it's very easy so if i want all of
the coordinates to have
you know some that some same bias p
i just don't start my process from zero
i started from that point
so you know if i start my process from
this point
and just continue as if you know it
walked up to here and then from here i'm
doing the same thing
again i'll get exactly the biased
process and and
every everything we did here also works
for biased
measures essentially
so the difference is that you don't
start in the origin but you start in a
different
place
okay so i see that questions are asked
in the chat so not all
participants can see them so maybe you
yeah yeah ah
so yeah so maybe i'll read the question
out loud
before answering so
can this approach apply to non-boolean
functions directly
i mean
almost none of the things i said
use the fact that the function is
boolean
in all of the proof i gave you the only
place where i use the fact that the
function is boolean
is that here at time one
the derivative has to end up at either
zero or one everything else
works just the same if the function is
not boolean
another question so
uh connections to continuous gritty
algorithms
um very good question
but i haven't thought about it
you know it's it kind of makes a lot of
sense
that you can like you want to maximize
some variance so you go along the
process and then you choose
like in a greedy way in which
which directions you sample first or
i don't know i mean it's i guess it's a
natural thing but they don't have
anything
clever to say um
is there anything any implication for
first passage percolation
so um
a consequence
are you still here
this computer seems to slow down
right
can can you hear me yes now yes
yeah i'm sorry my computer just ran out
of battery
it said 20 left five minutes ago
and i assumed those twenty percent are
going to be enough
for five minutes but apparently no
um yeah so so let me
let let me just answer without the
the board sorry about that
um so so this the
the short answer is i don't i i don't
have
anything rigorous to say about first
passage
anything new and rigorous to say about
first passage percolation
but it does give some characterization
of an event that has to happen
if this uh benjaminically sram
bound is dyed so since we characterize
the stability that that we basically
characterize the sharp cases
of telegrams inequality this immediately
gives some
characterization of this of of what
happens
if uh
if this result on first passage
percolation is sharp
um i i guess i could talk more about
that but it
would be hard without you know making
all the definitions
um
[Music]
are there more questions i can't see the
yeah so i
i have a question i don't know if this
is a short answer but
uh it seemed like uh you applied
essentially the same inequality on every
path
of your uh every part of your
brown emotion of the way you sampled but
somehow still looking at the granularity
of parts
was useful like it still was
why so
yeah that's a very good question so in
the
in everything i showed so far
it's you can somehow
uh bypass it and you don't
really really need to use anything about
the granularity of paths
but for the stability version for for
the actual
versions of the theorems it's it's
important
so you you really want
you're really using the facts that
if everything is sharp there has to be
at least
one coordinate that with a
non-negligible
probability reaches a high value
in its like effective influence in the
gradient of f
so maybe let me put it like this
okay let me put it like this
um the variance of martingale is equal
to the
expectation of the quadratic variation
and this is nice it gives us
things about the expectations of the
integrals that we wrote
but we actually know much more we know
that not only in expectation the
quadratic
variation is large but also with high
probability
it's larger than a constant so
with high probability over our path
space
we we see a pass path where
the gradient has to be large at some
point
and this is something that
so so i mean so you definitely
can't get everything just by taking
expectations
all right so the next talk will be the
next wednesday by
st on random restrictions
see you all next wednesday and tuesday
at 10 a.m